bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors c'est presque
unanimement les organisations lycéennes
qui crient au scandale
selon vous il ya des éléments concrets
qui couve la connivence entre cette
association et le ministère comme
l'affirment la presse bah écoute et déjà
du côté de gnl on a une certitude c'est
qu'à venir lycéens n'est pas là pour
rire comme par hasard cette association
apparaît pendant les mobilisations 2008
des lycéennes et je sais pas s'il vous
remettez en question les les sujets les
articles de libération et de mediapart
mais bon à mon avis c'est quand même une
affaire très sérieuse
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça bah
écoutez donner de l'argent à des lycéens
les subventionner je vais juste vous
dire quelque chose en tête cette
association donc qui est apparue en
décembre 2018 a été subventionné pour
l'année 2009 soit une année après sa
création
aucun autre syndicaliste a eu sa om enel
on existe depuis 2016 notre subvention
elle a dix mille euros pour 2019 et elle
a été à zéro euro pour 2020 alors que la
ja 65 mille euros c'est ça de
subventions d'ailleurs le syndicat est
lui aussi a accusé cette fois ci par
mediapart d'avoir dilapidé ses
subventions en frais de bouche dispense
urnes hôtel de luxe
quoi qu'il en soit il s'agit de deux
somme assez importante par rapport c'est
ce que vous nous expliquer aux
subventions qu'on reçoive normalement
les syndicats étudiants ou lycéens
bien entendu bien entendu nous a une
elle remettra jamais la faute sur les
lycéens parce qu'ils ont été manipulés
par un gouvernement
je comprends pas comment jean michel
bleu blanc caire peut encore se regarder
dans le miroir en ayant sur la
conscience qu'il est donné de l'argent à
des mineurs pour servir son propre
intérêt pour avoir ses propres
interlocuteur c'est un scandale c'est
honteux
aujourd'hui vous en tant que syndicat
lycéen vous avez envie de réagir comment
quelle est votre marge de manoeuvre
parce que c'est une affaire délicate
pour le moment il n'y a pas de preuve
c'est ce qu'affirme voilà le journal
libération aujourd'hui on imagine qu'une
enquête n'a pas encore été menée donc
c'est toujours à manier
avec beaucoup de prudence ces
accusations évidemment bien entendu il
faut savoir que de notre côté du côté
des syndicalistes d'extrême gauche je
reprends les propos de notre cher
ministre
on se prend des pressions parce que ils
veulent retourner la commission contre
nous mais là je vais faire un message
ouvert si jamais jamais c'est si jamais
jean michel blanquer on ne regarde jean
michel blanquer on n'a pas peur on est
prêt à faire partie de cette commission
si on n'a rien à cacher on n'est pas
comme vous alors on comprend qu'il ya
quand même des petits règlements de
compte
voilà entre les syndicats qui on le
rappelle c'est aussi intéressant pour
nos téléspectateurs parce qu'on doit
être objectifs sont souvent politisé
également vous ne vous en cachez pas
vous même c'est jean michel bloc'h air
qui a tenu de tels propos moi je peux
vous dire qu'au sein des mesnel on a des
on a des jeunes de tout horizon de
milieux populaires de milieux un petit
peu plus bourgeois on a aussi des les
hommes des femmes
on a de la diversité c'est ça en fait
qui fait un syndicat on n'est pas
derrière un seul parti on est derrière
aucun parti d'ailleurs ce sont juste les
idéaux qui nous fout qu'ils nous
tiennent debout alors pour le moment à
venir lycéens à un syndicat remis en
cause mis en cause plutôt défend son
indépendance et ne met en cause à aucun
moment le ministère vous avez quand même
confiance en vos collègues étudiants
bah écoutez moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'à venir lycéens
depuis sa création a eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de démission c'est du
jamais vu dans l'histoire du
syndicalisme policière donc c'est pas
anodin à mon avis merci en harivelo
randrianarisoa secrétaire du mouvement
national lycéens merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france